bienvenue dans le débat politique
manifestation de soutien aux
sans-papiers aujourd'hui à paris à
l'appel du collectif la marche de
solidarité relayé par 210 organisation
et quelques 300 personnalités une
manifestation pourtant interdite jeudi
par le préfet de police de paris didier
lallement pour mais brit au mépris des
règles sanitaires le cortège s'est donc
élancé de la place de la madeleine à la
place de la république et la police a
laissé faire pour en débattre
nous sommes avec lydia guirous ccic
ancien porte-parole des républicains
bonsoir lydia guirous ce et florian
philippot conseiller régional du grand
est et président des patriotes bonsoir
florian philippot merci à tous les deux
d'être là pour débattre de cette
manifestation sauvage on va d'abord
écouter les migrants et leurs
revendications et on en parle après on
est là à poser le papier on n'est pas la
cause pour tuer quelqu'un
on n'est pas un voleur on n'est pas pour
gaspare quelque chose inversement les
papiers pour travailler quand même tu
sais on a travaillé beaucoup de pays on
est on apprend à dépasser et à l'ue
espagne beaucoup de pays plus de neuf
ans ici
florian philippot votre réaction d'abord
à cette manifestation qui s'est tenue en
dépit de l'interdiction je rappelle
qu'on est encore en avec des règles
sanitaires à respecter et les
regroupements de dix personnes sont
toujours interdits c'était là le motif
de cette interdiction aujourd'hui qu'en
pensez vous mais moi j'avais vu il ya
quelques jours dizaines de gilet jaune
qui s'étaient réunies et il avait été
victime d'une répression d'un rappel à
la loi et un moment brutale et sans
aucune faiblesse
il a été attrapé par la police
rapidement voilà c'est verbaliser je
précise effectivement voilà là je
constate que il a été en tout cas pas
pas énormément mais on a vu quelques
lacs simo ici et là bien sûr mais didier
lallement le préfet de police de paris
nous a habitués à beaucoup plus de
rigueur quand il s'agissait les gilet
jaune et quelques mois ou même des
personnels soignants au mois de février
encore où les pompiers
là on a laissé faire alors que c'était
parfaitement illégal effectivement voilà
je lui faut pas être naïf derrière six
rassemblements que le v10 il ya 200 et
quelques associations
j'ai vu des banderoles rédigées en
magnifique écriture inclusive pour les
migrants migrantes point e point s etc
par des agrégés de france et inclusif ce
ne sont pas avec leur destin qu'ils ont
rédigé ce sont des associations derrière
très militante très politisé avec
d'ailleurs généralement des gens qui
sont pas du tout de ces milieux là qui
généralement ne disent pas dans les
quartiers d'ailleurs où il y à des camps
de migrants de nous-mêmes d'immigration
massive
donc je pense que c'est trop bête night
d'abord et c'est d'abord inadmissible ce
sont des gens qui sont là dans
l'illégalité et je rappelle que si ils
sont clandestins c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
le droit ils n'ont pas de titre séjour
légal pour être en france quant à
l'opportunité aujourd'hui dans un pays
qui quand même connaît rien que 11 mars
843 mille chômeurs de plus de les
régulariser ou même d'accepter toute
immigration supplémentaires moi ça me
paraît dingue on va rentrer dans une
crise économique et sociale massive dans
un chômage galopant et on n'a absolument
pas besoin et on n'a surtout pas intérêt
maintenant à subir une immigration
massive supplémentaire mais on parlera
de cuivre
derrière tout ça parce que ça fait le
beurre de quelques-uns cette immigration
massive serait pas le beurre d'ailleurs
de ces migrants clandestins qui sont
exploitées ça fait le beurre de gens qui
sont beaucoup plus au dessus est
beaucoup plus riche
les ja garros votre réaction à cette
manifestation sauvage rappelle quand
même que ces personnes travaillent en
france travaillent de façon à dissimuler
dans les champs par exemple pendant le
confinement ou alors ramassage de
poubelles et autres ces personnes on
continue à travailler pendant le
confinement
elles sont néanmoins effectivement dans
l'illégalité
lydia guirous ce votre réaction pourquoi
aujourd'hui alors qu'on est encore dans
le temps dans crise sanitaire et donc
avec certaines règles à respecter
je partage beaucoup de ce qui a été dit
par florian philippot oui en effet ces
personnes sont pour certaines d'entre
elles continuent à travailler ont
participé à faire vivre aussi
je dirais la france dans des eaux qui
sont très difficiles
néanmoins ils sont arrivés de manière
illégale en france il ya des règles et
ce n'est pas entre aux manifestants
alors que les manifestations sont
interdites les rassemblements de plus de
dix personnes sont interdits pour
l'ensemble des français on sort tout
juste des périodes de confinement que
qui peuvent être régularisés ça fait
également suite et c'est vrai qu'il est
intéressant de savoir qui qui sont les
organisateurs quelles sont les
associations qui les instrumentalisent
pour bien comprendre les questions donc
un point d'ancrage france terre d'asile
et qui va voilà toutes les associations
qui défendent habituellement les
migrants c'est surprenant de voir des
panneaux en accrue dans l'écriture en
cuisine ça fait suite aussi à cette
tribune qui avait été rédigé par
quelques députés il me semble dont
certains étaient de la république en
marche pour demander une régularisation
massive au nom de la crise sanitaire des
des sans papiers mais effectivement nous
allons entrer dans une période comme il
ya déjà en réalité de crise économique
avec un chauffeur à un chômage qui va
être très important qui va impacter les
jeunes qui va impacter les personnes de
ma génération également et je ne crois
pas que nous aurons la possibilité
d'intégrer ces personnes qui demandent à
être régularisés même si l'on est un
parcours extrêmement difficile ils ont
pour certains d'entre eux fuient des
pays avec les plus grandes difficultés
on peut comprendre mais la réalité
pragmatisme veut qu' il ya des règles en
france et on n'a pas et on ne peut pas
il ya des règles et puis il ya surtout
une réalité économique et sociale qui
fait qu'on pourra pas régularisé et
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'une immigration
massive actuellement alors vous avez
parlé effectivement deux de ses
parlementaires qui ont adressé une
tribune à edouard philippe c'était le 12
avril dernier ils réclamaient la
régularisation provisoire de ces
migrants pendant la crise sanitaire
écoutez la réaction de ce qu'a répondu
edouard philippe justement lui le 17
avril
une mesure temporaire d'accès au séjour
pour assurer l'accès aux soins des
étrangers dans le contexte épidémique
actuel les pas nécessaires
edouard philippe a estimé que ce n'était
pas nécessaire
florian philippot c'est vrai que ces
migrants quoi qu'on en dise il était sur
le sol quand le confinement a commencé
des centres ont commencé à fermer
certaines associations disent que les
conditions sanitaires n'était pas
satisfaisante étant donné la crise qu
aurait dû faire le gouvernement selon
vous c'est une question beaucoup plus
vaste qu'est ce que c'est qu est-ce qu
réduit faire tous les gouvernements
depuis des décennies en réalité parce
que sur le territoire national dont il
ya des évaluations gérard collomb n'en
parlais tout à l'heure en pâte en
quittant ministère avait dit qu'il y
avait 300 mille clandestins sur le
territoire national d'autres évaluations
disent que c'est le doux pensez pas à
moins 4 500 milles à peu près il ya un
demi million on peut imaginer qu'un demi
million de clandestins en permanence en
france et que ce chiffre est plutôt à la
route année après année
bon bah il faudrait faire appliquer la
loi déjà qu'il faudrait que notre pays
ait des frontières nationales ne
faudrait surtout comprendre que ça sert
les intérêts quelques uns qui qui les
instrumentalisent ces gens là ce sont
des gens qui ont intérêt à avoir les
travailleurs dissimulé à le payer qui
vont pas revendiqué qui vont accepter de
ne pas avoir de contrat de travail etc
c'est donc au pourquoi tous les rapports
du grand patronat en france et en europe
demandent toujours plus d'immigration
depuis des années parce qu'ils y ont
leurs intérêts économiques
il ya un intérêt de taux de marge on
sait que c'est aussi le projet de
monsieur soros avec toutes ces
fondations ces ong ces associations qui
sont derrière généralement qu'il finance
toutes ces associations qui militent
pour la régularisation sans aucune
limite d'ailleurs pas qu'en france 2 des
clandestins savez on parle beaucoup du
monde d'après le monde après ça devrait
être un monde un peu plus équilibré
parce que ça me fait de bien à personne
cette affaire l'immigration massive ça
n'est plus acceptée en france
et pour cause et ça le sera de moins
demain on va être en crise économique et
sociale absolument massif faut pas
s'imaginer que les français vont
accepter plus d'immigration
il est évident qu'ils vont accepter -
c'est tout à fait juste
pragmatique et comme disait didier
hausse est logique mais c'est pas vous
non plus pour les pays d'origine c'est à
dire pour le continent africain
notamment de ceux qui gagnent beaucoup
du continent africain n'a absolument pas
que vous vous discutez vraiment avec des
gens là-bas des africains qui sont qui
veulent le développement et bonheur de
leur pays ils sont pas heureux de voir
cela ils n'ont pas envie de ça ils
savent très bien que ça sert les mêmes
flux économiques et financiers dont on
vient de parler
donc si on veut un monde plus équilibré
qui serait le vrai monde d'après si
vraiment on veut changer les règles je
pas sûr que une vraie volonté de le
faire mais si vraiment on veut changer
les rails alors on doit se mettre
d'accord avec ces pays d'origine on doit
trouver des solutions
on doit faire trois aussi parfois de
pression aux moyens de pression de
coercition quand c'est nécessaire
vis-à-vis de ces pays d'origine qu'on ne
sont pas réponse ils sont tout
simplement laxistes ils laissent faire
pour trouver des solutions que chacun
développe son pays
on peut pas continuer dans un monde
pareil il faut réguler les flux
marchandises dont l'atout si les flux
financiers il faut aussi réguler les
flux mme
parce que c'est c'est seule personne
n'est gagnant dans cette affaire à part
quelques-uns qui se font le beurre leur
beurre sur sur ces gens mais qui les
exploitent franchement c'est pas un
projet humaniste et on doit le combattre
de toutes nos forces
la crise sanitaire avait un peu réfréner
les ardeurs des candidats au départ avec
la crise sanitaire on a vu que avec le
lot des confinement des bateaux avaient
recommencé à venir sur les côtes
il ya eu un drame encore récemment lydia
guirous ce c'est une question qui n'a
pas beaucoup été entendus dans la parole
publique que ce soit au niveau national
ou européen
c'était pourtant une question toujours
d'actualité comme tous les autres
domaines d'ailleurs la question refait
surface mais on régularise ainsi on
régularise sans papiers en réalité on se
rend en quelque part complice de tous
ces trafiquants d'êtres humains qui les
font passer dans des bateaux de fortune
traverser la méditerranée au péril de
leur vie après la vie après les affaires
après les avoir pas l'honneur de la
france ou de l'europe de participer à ce
trafic là il faut agir en amour est
aussi une question de look
il ya eu un procès cette semaine pour
justement pour des passeurs bien sûr
aimé mais il faut poursuivre davantage
et sous que les dossiers soient traités
en afrique pour éviter que l'autre que
ces personnes traversent la méditerranée
que la méditerranée devienne un
cimetière de de gens qui n'ont aucun
espoir c'est d'avoir une vie meilleure
il faut aussi mettre un peu plus la
pression sur les pays africains afin
qu'ils se développent parce qu'ils
reçoivent des millions à des dizaines
des centaines de millions d aide au
développement sans retenir leurs
populations et il faut conditionner ses
aides au développement au fait qu'il
maintienne et qui donne d'ailleurs les
laissez passer consulaires afin de
pouvoir reconduire à la frontière ceux
qui sont arrivés chez nous de manière
illégale
donc c'est vrai que le continent
africain qui connaît une explosion à
démographique extrêmement importante qui
va poursuivre dans les années à venir ne
doit pas et ne doit pas avoir pour seul
horizon pour sa jeunesse d'être entre
les mains de trafiquants d'êtres humains
de traverser au péril de leur vie la
méditerranée ils doivent pouvoir avoir
un horizon dans leur pays je pense que
c'est à ceux-là qu'aspire les jeunes
africains en réalité nous ont la
capacité de se développer et leur avenir
n'est pas uniquement en europe et pas
uniquement en france
c'est à cela que des gouvernants
responsable et respectueux de ces
personnes doivent travailler aujourd'hui
quitte à mettre la pression sur les
gouvernants africains s'ils ne sont pas
au rendez vous on va revenir sur sur
cette manifestation aujourd'hui à paris
et dans d'autres villes de france
l'article 7 du décret du 11 mai
stipulait que il ne fallait pas se
réunira plus de 10 personnes regardaient
le communiqué de la préfecture de police
pour interdire cette manifestation je
rappelle que l'île de france est
toujours en zone orange
cette déclaration contrevient l'article
7 du décret du 11 mai 2020 qui interdit
tout rassemblement réunion ou activités
un titre autres que professionnelles sur
la voie publique ou dans un lieu public
mettant en présence simultanée plus de
10 personnes
didier lallement préfet de police a donc
décidé d'interdire ce rassemblement les
risques sanitaires qu'un tel événement
est susceptible
générer justifie que le préfet de police
n'autorise pas à titre dérogatoire cette
manifestation florian philippot les
manifestants avaient promis de mettre
des masques et de respecter les
distanciation on a vu sur les images que
ça n'avait pas été le cas les
responsables porterait une
responsabilité en cas de propagation du
virus
moi je pense que si vous voulez que
honnêtement je suis assez optimiste deux
sanglots je pense que le virus est
plutôt en train de des quasi gandhi a
quasiment disparu de france
je suis pas médecin donc je lis je vois
un peu ce qui se passe j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya pas grand risque
bon on espère qu'il aura pas que de
contamination qui se sera pas un foyer
de contamination évidemment faut faire
attention mais là si vous voulez y avait
une hypocrisie de la préfecture de
police l'a interdit passons à la toile
devait les interdire mais imaginez si
6000 gilet jaune avaient décidé de faire
la même chose au nom du ou des masques
jouer là ils étaient 5000 haut de gamme
et les 5000 on va vous vous auriez des
scènes ce soir d'une brutalité inouïe on
ne pas rire et vous on n'aurait pas
laissé faire du tout de la même manière
les choses certainement pas là on amène
un député je crois à elle vers députés
verts qui a pris la parole au micro
devant tout le monde comme un meeting je
pense que même
même les députés auraient été d'un mis
de côté comme on l'a vu un des élus
avaient été mis côté de ceux qui
soutenaient les gilets jaunes dans les
manifestations donc si vous voulez il ya
gradins de production qui est
insupportable
ou alors on considère que des puits des
vides à peu près terminée et on redonne
la liberté aux français de se rassembler
et de faire des manifestations parce
qu'il faudra pas que cette règle des dix
personnes dans l'espace public soit
utilisé comme contrôle social contrôle
politique contre la colère légitime des
français parce que ça ça va finir par se
voir
donc on laisserait faire certaines
manifestations qui sont finalement pas
très dérangeant de promouvoir ce genre
de manifestation n'est pas très
dérangeante pour le pouvoir
par contre on serait impitoyable avec
les vraies manifestations qui pose les
vrais sujets ceux touchant à la gestion
de cette crise se touchant l'oligarchie
ceux touchant à la répartition des
richesses se touchant à l'union
européenne aux frais visites etc
voyez donc voila moi c'est ce que je
vois je pense que beaucoup de français
pensent la même chose se disent il ya
quand même un deux poids deux mesures
insupportable charge ou juste un point
sur le fond pensez pas qu un pays qui va
avoir dix points de récession cette
année parce que c'est manifestement ce
qui va se passer et cadeau qui va donc
détruire plus
200 milliards d'euros de richesse cette
année qui va avoir un chômage en
expansion exponentielle va accepter de
migrations massives c'est évident que
non et c'est juste c'est pas raciste ou
méchant de ne pas l'accepter c'est juste
normal c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer
et donc ce genre de manifestation va
rendre fou les français si on continue
d'accepter tout ça on verra on vérifiera
avec le temps florian philippot ligue 1
vous êtes d'accord il ya un deux poids
deux mesures dans la gestion des
manifestations sauvages
oui je suis je suis très surprise par la
gestion de cette manifestation d'abord
je voudrais rappeler que quand tu
manifestation est interdite
on respecte la règle et surtout quand on
veut appartenir à une nation et en cela
je trouve que les associations puissent
instrumentaliser ces sans papiers n'ont
envoyé un signal je vous aurais pu
manifester après il aurait pu attendre
je pense que ce n'était pas le bon
moment et ça envoie un très mauvais
signal et un signaleur qui peut aussi
qui peut aussi faire progresser
l'extrême droite quelques paraissait et
c'est dramatique parce qu'ils sont
doublement instrumentalisé ses fins et
c'est contre-productif et je suis
surprise aussi par le manque de par le
fait que le préfet de police de paris
monsieur l'allemand qui nous avait
habitués à des discours martiaux a
énormément de rigueur on ne le voit pas
cette fois ci c'est très surprenant
pourtant il ne rate jamais une occasion
d'avoir une phrase très forte pour
marquer son autorité
donc c'est vrai que la gestion de cette
manifestation peut poser quelques
quelques questions est ce que je crains
comme florian et nicolas indiqué c'est
que ceux-ci ce type de manifestations se
multiplient dans le contexte social et
économique qui arrivent et qui va être
dramatique pour l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises dans lors de nos débats sur
votre chaise ça sera une promotion pour
pour l'extrême droite et c'est
dramatique
donc les associations et les élus qui
sont derrière tout ça avec un projet
électoraliste sont en train de mettre
dans l'eau du moulin de l'extrême droite
et c'est un jeu extrêmement dangereux
pour notre pays un moment où on
s'apprête à aborder joue qui vont être
très très difficile et il nous reste
très peu de temps florian philippot vous
avez 30 secondes est ce que le moment
choisi et et judicieux ça peut être très
couvert par les médias en début
d'après-midi un ben voilà c'est vrai que
le préfet l'allemand olaf a vu cette
fois ci il était caché dans sa casquette
vous je sais parler on n'a pas
l'habitude lui qui est effectivement
multiplie les remarques parfois
provocantes
ben il avait dit elle gilet jaune mal à
nous ne sommes pas du même camp là
raconte il ne le dit pas évidemment
voilà moi c'est tout ce que j'ai à ce
que j'ai à dire sans les âges et dans ce
genre de manifestation pour le pouvoir
ça n'est pas gênant et ça sert les
intérêts de quelques grand patronat qui
sont bien bien copain avec avec le
pouvoir
et derrière c'est une association
creusant un peu on trouve aussi souvent
monsieur chambre ce qui est en train de
déstabiliser beaucoup de nations comme
il le fait depuis des années
alors ça ça reste et c'est également à
vérifier merci en tout cas merci
beaucoup florian philippot merci media
games d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est
la fin du débat politique
restez avec nous sur rt france